welcome to this video playing cow from
the US who is that I like irregular
setups okay let's see what is how
irregular is going to play it that looks
fairly regular just the Italian game
okay what do I get in 94 he gives me the
bishops that's nice maybe can go pee
should be 60 that's not a not a problem
then yeah okay I see huh okay let's
let's install that pin and ask him about
it now that pin is always a bit annoying
and it's not so easy to get rid of it so
let's see I wonder I wonder
and let's let's cancel 93 something that
I might go for if he takes it only three
the F file will open to my advantage Oh
interesting
interesting idea hmm didn't think about
that move champion okay let's keep
pieces on the board I want this
deformable okay he allows that let's do
it so
can I wonder yeah but this is that that
that is almost always useful
okay you cannot go d5 that's not not
happening let's get out of the default
anyway and prevent g5 and the process
altogether yeah okay maybe he wants to
go go into e6 in order to in order to
unpin that's possible
let's just prevented for the moment yeah
I can go 25 not not sure but I haven't
have a different idea if the bishops are
traded I'm might be able to use the
light squares with 94 or just now and we
can no I cannot sorry i was thinking it
can check here and play something to see
5 but may have to point is protected by
the bishop so that's no big deal 93 you
might have g5 of it it is very
materialistic but maybe he has that yeah
of course in a split second so if i take
is 6 Queen takes can I go nite a five
maybe yeah actually can
but even considering to check on e4
maybe maybe it was just bad of course
but I haven't I I think I know what his
ideas in this game he wants to win on
time that's the real idea which is very
plausible given that I spent so much so
he's currently tied a bit to some
weaknesses and I'm attacking a seven
which I might just take
it takes with the epod I go okay does he
place the other move here I can just
trade stuff or try to trade stuff I'm an
end game night against bishop would be
here would be nice here with this pawn
weaknesses
Bishop looks good on b6 but it's not so
clear what it is really doing I just get
something straight it it will be very
nice for me I actually expect something
like King h7 that that he tries to do
something on there on the G file Wow ok
check Queen age 593 that is my idea
Queen g3 is a funny move ok so probably
I have to be flexible he and adjust to
something else 92 and the King king over
to e2 and go from them yeah no it's not
G it's not bad if i go here time 183 he
maybe has f3 that could be an annoying
move no not doing that ok then let's
just regroup them to f3
yeah it's a fleshie move but it doesn't
do anything so not too easily entering
though Queen a4 it's not really netting
me that much it's probably not even that
great this is with tempo
I to be three can could be good good
move cannot go to be three now
unfortunately now I'm blundering porn
mmm stupid very stupid bra I'm drawing
here and doesn't want to know okay then
I will a time for effects on time and I
do more than offer it yeah okay before I
blundered the pawn I'm just much better
of course probably winning probably
winning and especially earlier around
here with some precise play I think
white should win this pretty
convincingly not completely sure how the
engine gives this as the way to do it
why it's probably ruined quince is seven
to cover that and then 95 it has to be
something like that is structured simply
too bad there were a couple of
surprising decisions around here I think
this is probably an equal ish position
he played here went here and then he
just played this and now politics and
night hy I thought he would take it
actually and I wasn't sure what happens
here I mean it will always be a bit of
compensation because he has totally kill
tubes didn't want to make that arrow did
he totally kill his structure I mean
something like this for example cannot
be terribly bad for me let's say it
takes I take and i have the square and
and then some light squared play the
computer says equal interesting yeah
maybe I'm getting a pawn back
somewhere those pawns are not
particularly strong he went here Queen
here the computer wants to do this and
that s that looks pretty good actually i
don't have a good square I have to
retreat check yeah that's good means
upset was a bit much didn't want you wow
we add what the software is doing so
natural for wasn't a good good move i
have to have to retreat him and this is
about equal according to the engine yeah
it's got activity he has weakened
himself a bit but it's quite active yet
the way the way it went it's sort of
oops he could have taken g3 what kind of
thing is that oops oops or what a bad
game wow you can just take g3 yeah
there's a pin Wow ok i'm still irritated
by that date i lost i guess i already
know what ok anyway i hope you enjoyed
that game even though it wasn't it
wasn't particularly good thanks for
watching